.
SPOKESMAN FOR THE UK PRIME
MINISTER SAYS MR. JOHNSON HAS SO
FAR NOT BEEN ISSUED WITH A FINE
HIMSELF.
>>> BRITAIN'S QUEEN ELIZABETH II
MAKES HER FIRST PUBLIC
APPEARANCE IN MONTHS TO PAY
TRIBUTE TO HER LATE HUSBAND OF
73 YEARS.
EARLIER TODAY MEMBERS OF THE
ROYAL FAMILY AND WORLD
DIGNITARIES ATTENDED A
THANKSGIVING SERVICE.
PRINCE PHILIP PASSED AWAY LAST
APRIL, TWO MONTHS BEFORE HIS
100th BIRTHDAY.
SHE HAS NOT ATTENDED A PUBLIC
EVENT SINCE FALLING ILL LATE
LAST YEAR FROM AN UNSPECIFIED
AILMENT.
LET'S BRING IN NINA DOS SANTOS
LIVE AT TEN DOWNING STREET.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE QUEEN IN
PUBLIC FOR MONTHS.
CLEARLY FOR ANYBODY WHO WAS
MARRIED TO SOMEBODY FOR 73
YEARS, A LIFE LONG PARTNER, OF
COURSE, AS WAS PRINCE PHILIP TO
THE QUEEN, THIS MUST HAVE BEEN
AN EMOTIONAL EVENT FOR HER.
>> Reporter: TERRIBLY EMOTIONAL.
AND IT WAS ALSO AN OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE THAT BIG FUNERAL THAT
HER LATE HUSBAND HAD TAKEN SUCH
DETAIL TO PLAN OVER THE YEARS,
FINALLY, BECAUSE, OF COURSE,
THEY COULDN'T HAVE THAT THIS
TIME LAST YEAR BECAUSE THE
LOCKDOWN RESTRICTIONS MEANT ONLY
30 PEOPLE COULD ATTEND HIS
FUNERAL.
SO THIS WAS AN EVENT THAT HAD
1,800 PEOPLE, MANY
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE DUKE'S
CHARITIES, BELOVED CAUSES, WERE
LINING THE ENTRANCE WAY TO
WESTMINSTER ABBEY AS THE CLEAN
WALKED PAST.
BUT SHE WAS ALSO FLANKED BY FOUR
GENERATIONS OF HER OWN FAMILY,
YOU'LL REMEMBER THE POIGNANT
IMAGES OF THE MONARCH, THIS TIME
LAST YEAR, HAVING TO SIT ON HER
OWN, OBSERVING THOSE LOCKDOWN
RESTRICTIONS THAT SOME OTHER
PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY HERE IN
DOWNING STREET ARE ACCUSED OF
NOT DOING SO AT THAT TIME.
AND BECKY, NOW FINALLY SHE WAS
ABLE TO SIT WITH HER OWN
CHILDREN, HER GRANDCHILDREN, HER
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN AS WELL.
THIS WAS AN IMPORTANT MOMENT FOR
HER, BUT THE CEREMONY HAD TO BE
TAILORED TO HER AGE, 45 MINUTES
BECAUSE WE KNOW THE QUEEN IS
QUITE ELDERLY AT THIS TIME, AND
SHE ALSO HAS BEEN STRUGGLING
WITH SOME MOBILITY ISSUES.
IT WAS ALSO A CHANCE TO SEE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE ROYAL
FAMILY WHO HAVE BEEN IN THE ABL
OF YORK.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME WE HAVE
SEEN HIM SINCE HIS LEGAL
TROUBLES WERE SETTLED IN THE
UNITED STATES.
HE HAD THE IMPORTANT ROLE OF
ACCOMPANYI